- Welcome back, y'all!
We're here with Gwen Stefani
and Melissa Villaseñor!
(audience cheering)
So Melissa's new book
"Whoops, I'm Awesome"
is all about awesome things
that she is obsessed with.
Meanwhile, we are all about to be obsessed
with Gwen's new cosmetic line GXVE Beauty.
- Whoo!
(audience cheering)
- So right now is a good time
for another round of obsessions.
(audience cheering)
Okay. That's right.
It is time, once again, to own
our sometimes weird obsessions.
Um, I'm going to hit this button,
and a topic will be selected
by our super random, super computer,
which apparently couldn't
be upgraded for season four.
I thought we were doing
well, but maybe next year.
(laughing)
Then, the person obsessed
with the topic will own up
and sell us, um, on
whatever it is they love,
that they're obsessed with.
So I'm going to get us
started with something
I currently love.
- [Super Computer] Obsessions.
- Obsessions.
Oh my.
This is not like, I love four-wheeling.
Everyone loves four-wheeling.
- Hold up. What's four-wheeling?
(laughing)
Do you know?
- I mean are you talking about
like four-wheeling, like that?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Four-wheeling.
- Yeah, like...
- Yeah, like on a four-wheeler.
- Oh! I thought first
like the third wheel,
but there's four...
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly Clarkson] But there's two extra.
- That doesn't make sense.
- Oh my God.
I love where your brain went. No.
- Two friends between a couple
in love like, just like "Yes!"
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my God!
- Stupid!
- That became a very different party.
Um, so, um, no, I love, I
think you can get behind this,
Four-wheeling, like, I spend
my whole summer literally
four-wheeling in the mountains.
- Oh. I would love that.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah, you're in nature.
It's so fun!
Yeah. That's not,
I don't think that's a weird obsession.
You like four-wheeling?
- I almost killed my best friend
on one of those.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh!
- I went, like, I hit the
gas when I thought it was
and you know, the brake...
I don't know.
I wasn't very good at it.
So, no more.
(audience laughing, clapping)
- Oh my.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh, they're so free-ing.
- But I did like it. I do like it.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- It's super fun.
- I love it too,
cause like you're in
control of your own speed.
You're not in a vehicle with
everybody else, it's just you.
I love that part.
Maybe that comes down to control.
Okay. Um, Melissa's next.
- [Super Computer] Obsessions.
(laughing)
- Cream of Wheat?
- Let me explain before
everyone judges me, okay?
- I love that.
- I really love Cream of Wheat.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay....
- It's something my mom
and I just, it's our thing.
You know?
Sometimes at late at night when we're like
"What do we eat?"
You know?
And our bellies don't
want something heavy.
We make some, whip up some Cream of Wheat.
I'm a little old lady.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly Clarkson] And
no, here's the thing.
(laughing)
I need an answer though,
because I don't actually
know the difference.
What's the difference?
Because I do that sometimes
with oatmeal with my son.
Is oatmeal Cream of Wheat,
is that kind of similar?
What's Cream of Wheat?
- Yeah, it's in the same family you know?
- I don't think I know
what Cream of Wheat is.
- It's more like wheat,
but like kind of porridgey.
Do you put butter in, and sugar?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh, I don't like grits.
It's like grits.
- It's like a grits. Yes.
- It's like a grits.
- Yes.
- I don't like grits.
- It's more wheaty than a grits.
- Okay. Don't come over at night okay.
(audience laughing)
Scooping up a lot of Cream of Wheat.
- I have my oatmeal.
You have your Cream of Wheat.
Do you like Cream of Wheat?
Are you a grits girl?
- I do. I like everything almost.
- Okay. I almost do.
Okay. Okay wait.
Gwen's turn.
- Yay. What do I love.
- [Super Computer] Obsessions.
- Yes.
- Ooh.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah. I have grown up
with the Sound of Music
being my biggest
inspiration my whole life.
I did a video based on it.
I did a song with her, like,
song in it, and um it's just
it's just one of those
things that will never end,
the Sound of Music.
I'm just always obsessed
with Julie Andrews,
and the Sound of Music.
(audience clapping)
- What's your favorite part of the film?
- Of the film?
There is one part that I
have watched since I was
a little girl over and over
and over and over and over.
and over again.
What's your, what's your favorite part?
- Well, I talk about fashion.
I recreated, the first time
I ever was on stage, ever
um, for a high school talent show.
I remade the dress that she wears,
when she sings I have confidence.
It's like drop away, true, like tweed.
- Yeah.
Strolling down the lane with a suitcase.
- Yeah. It's the dress that
the, the little girl goes, um
that's the ugliest dress I've ever seen.
And so, like that's
probably my favorite moment,
cause it's a big part.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I love that!
- Isn't that funny?
- What a great song too,
for that like a little kid to love.
- Yea
- I love that.
Mine is when they talk over
each other, since you asked.
(laughing)
Um, mine is when they're in
like the gazebo towards the end,
and you know the captain
earlier in there and then
they kind of talk over each
other and they're like, wait
what? And then it comes
together and you're like, okay.
- [Gwen Stefani] Oh my gosh.
- I love that part.
- That song, that song is crazy.
I must've had it with you.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes! I know.
Yeah. Love it.
- That's a good moment.
You like sound music?
- I I I need to re-watch it,
cause the two things you
brought up, I don't remember.
- What!
(audience laughing)
- I maybe I watched a lot,
the, the two and the Gazebo.
Like I am 16.
Yeah, that one.
- Yes. That's actually my least
favorite part of the movie.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, okay. I wasn't,
that wasn't my favorite.
- No, no, no. I'm not doubting it.
I'm just, I just meant like
out of the whole movie.
I don't know why, that
was my least favorite.
I don't know.
Anyway. Okay, everybody, those are our
- Obsessions.
(audience cheering)